what's harder to win an nba finals or a
super bowl
super bowl why you only get one shot
right because you could be a better team
17 weeks out of 17 and still lose on
that super bowl sunday
[Music]
welcome to another episode of full
bodied i'm channing frye here with cam
jordan the pride and joy of the chandler
wolves
thank you for being on the show with us
as the wine gets darker the questions
gonna get deeper hey what's up how is
everybody wonderful
yes saints may or may not win us who
bowl this year guarantee you that you
might be one of the coolest people i've
never met and i feel like i've met a lot
of cool people so cheers and we're going
to get this thing started
so this first one is a savion blanc and
sav blanc is generally known as like an
old school wine but a lot of people are
doing it differently now and so my first
question is
how are the saints
going to be
better how are they going to reinvent
themselves no as we talked about this
wine it's definitely dawn of a new age
you know drew brees just retired we're
headed into a new leadership position in
the quarterback room
but at the same time in the last three
years you've seen a culture shift as
well it hasn't just been the new orleans
saints offense you now have the defense
that comes too and so when you think
about our defense we've got leadership
at every position right right where you
know it's a stalwart where we can be
dependable so i think that our
leadership will come from our defense
but we talk about offense you still have
ak which is probably the best
well-balanced all-around running back
you're going to catch in the league
you're making me want to buy a saints
jersey
i mean you talk about what he's able to
do on the field whether it's running
between guards bouncing outside catching
the rock i mean the moment he hits open
space it's a full-blown problem i
remember he came in his rookie year and
i tried to smack him like yeah it's his
training camp and i was like i'ma test
what he's worth you know like and so i
went to go smash him and i think he like
i lifted him at least two feet in there
you know like he released i was like i
was like good hit clean hit i love it i
was like that was like welcome but he
lands like plants his foot down and was
like ready for the next move and i was
like oh he's different luckily it was
out of bounds so he was he was it
would've been
a game but you're late for rotation and
somebody goes to dunk and the ball
bounces so far you look like you see you
see jesus say you owe me one
you owe me one exactly i've almost got
boomed on one time and i was like i
would have to quit playing
basketball i would i can't go home i
can't see my family i can't see i gotta
just i gotta go work at best buy
channing what happened to you
you saw it you saw i got dunked so this
enthusiasm for the game and you've been
in there
for a long time for any nfl player
you're a pro bowler you're from chandler
arizona and funny enough i'm from
chandler arizona so
coming from where we come from why
football so pops played in nfl for 13
years six time pro bowler minnesota
vikings from phoenix went to south
phoenix eighth grade rolls around i'm
probably like five eight a buck ninety
something maybe two hundred i might have
been two hundred exactly it's a very
solid two hundred it's just
i'm still i'm dunking you know i'm i'm
dunking so you're bouncing back that's
what i'm saying i'm very explosive i was
a mini zion you know what i'm saying oh
yeah i i considered myself a point
before but it wasn't working out five
minutes on the b team like it wasn't
working out my way and then pops was
like i don't want to be that dad but
here's your pads you got practice he
just drops me off throws the pads at me
and i'm pissed i'm sitting at practice
like i don't want this like what am i
doing here i was like i'm a hooper like
i sho i was like i'm like splash water
that's me i'm looking up to guys like
amari right right right
sean marion steve nash i'm thinking like
the whole sun's roster i'm like man i'm
going to be one of them one day like
you're right messing up my dreams here
and then moving on to college why cal
why not arizona why not arizona state
arizona state had like that weird like
college coach transition like one call
one coach at connell coaches coming in
and then oregon state really loved me
oregon state had a lot of love for me
but he kept wanting to make me into a a
guard
yeah he was like you could be a hall of
famer gold jacket guard right like i do
way too much athletically for me to be a
fatten person like
and and i'm confessed to all the guards
all offense what do you mean i go out of
my way to make a fence off the line like
you know like those sloppy bigs in
in the league they're like oh you can't
teach size when somebody gets labeled
you can't teach size
you know
like that's what he is like he woke up
and was 350 pounds like
not trying who is somebody
that you are like you respect them but
you like
love just mushing them
it could be a quarterback it could be a
running it's an entire team i love
atlanta falcons like for everything that
they are bro they're a phenomenal team
they have top tier talent from
quarterback matt ryan he had an mvp
season and what like 2016 2017 they had
judio jones up my entire career who just
went over to tennessee they just drafted
this kid from university of florida kyle
pitts i think he could be special yeah
but i'm gonna put hands on all of them
regardless like i expect to win like the
rivalry between these two cities new
orleans and atlanta is
real in a lot of
my early career it was like tough for us
to get the playoffs we'd have to beat
atlanta you know like we going to
thanksgiving hey we got to beat these
these dirty birds we beat them we lock
in playoffs and we smack the hell out of
whether it be at our house their house
we're eating turkey legs on the 50-yard
line we're singing dancing and one
because there's never been a defensive
player to sack one said quarterback of a
team more times than what me and matt
ryan have together we have a special
symbiotic relationship
um over 10 seasons there's been an
amassed 21 sack without him i would only
have 73 sacks you know
i appreciate him for at least a fourth
so we were just talking about people you
love to smack and lay down and whisper
sweet nothings to and that's obviously
matt ryan who in your opinion are the
top five quarterbacks right now in
today's game
man and i'll say
when you say top five it's like it's
like when you get to that top one tier
you can like interchange them you know
my dog drew just retired so i don't have
to worry about putting this here right
right so then you've got
russ wilson
aaron rodgers matthew safford oh
big arm pat holmes
and then i'm either tied it's either tom
brady or lamar jack tom brady is
fighting for fifth because he's the most
accomplished yeah but if you look at
like stat lines throws whatever it is
you wouldn't be like he's clearly he's
just he is chris paul when it comes to
the game like he's gonna nickel and dime
every mistake you oh you gonna give me
this boop okay five yards he's so
methodical what he does he's the most
accomplished nfl player probably ever
when i think goat i think like dion
sanders i think you know athletically
like gift from god right you know what
i'm saying like one of those megatrons
one of the aps you know the bo jackson
you look at him you like bro go yeah i
look at tom and i like most accomplished
ever right but i just think like my
athletic goat right probably because i
messed up and said athletic goat like
right right i don't think quarterbacks
are in that realm of goat talk because i
think they can bring roethlisberger this
thing i think you know they could be
what possible hall of famers and
never work out when i retired from
basketball i realized that wine was my
dream outside of the dream and i also
realized i had to do it my way by
creating my own wine label chosen family
wines and in this segment we're going to
dive into my guest dreams brought to you
by porsche so we got this carpronk this
is actually delicious this palazzo and i
think for me cupronk is that usually
this is something that's mixed in with
other things you're starting your own
podcast big trust which i checked out
you're in a fashion you're a team jordan
guy so
cam what is one of the greatest
accomplishments of your career so far
you know i feel like
in my life i've probably cried three
times once when i was born the first
time my mom like getting my ass whooping
come on and the time my wife said we
were pregnant with the sun and i was
like it comes full circle my dad had me
i'm blessed to play in the league it was
like yo the legacy continues and i'm big
on legacy i i appreciate everything that
i've ever learned from both my parents
what is your dream job after
happening had you asked me that my first
five years in the league my dream job
would have been a pe teacher i was like
bro i'm gonna be a pe teacher what do
you think i went to college for
well you have to get your pe teacher
degree to coach i want to coach high
school whatever i do i'm always in the
community i'm always trying to impart
some sort of knowledge on kids earlier
this last week i was at a football camp
but it's like just talking to these kids
they try and draw so much knowledge from
you but they give back so much energy
it's a give and take and it's like bro
that's how i swear people stay youthful
forever well you're in the podcasting so
you have your podcast hey big trust
levels big trust yeah yeah just released
your episodes are funny they're really
good and i think like your guys's
chemistry is worth people's watch so
where did that come from my boy we got
drafted together we played in new
orleans for eight years together i was
like bro like
between me and him we know at least 50
to me yeah i was like we could we could
have fun calling people in whatever it
is
talking it's talking [ __ ] and having fun
totally who doesn't like that it's the
best
this personality of yours
were you always like this or was there
somebody that like you would say
inspired you to be like i got me a lot
of ass opens when i was younger yeah
i've always been this
like for instance you send wine to
somebody that was a beautiful bottle of
jordan cab i mean jordan is delicious i
sent him my best vintage too assimilated
2011 i really enjoyed that year that's a
great year it was a phenomenal year
another day
i'm just saying tell the story of who
you sent the wine to and why we had
trounced the the carolina panthers
yeah we beat them the first time and i
think it was a close game we beat them
the second time and i think it was a
little bit farther stretched so now
they've got some salt in their wounds
you know the first game i think i got a
question about how fashionable he was
and i was like oh yeah you know like
he's got auntie swag on the thousand you
know it was
swag too and it was like it was like it
was like one of these playful
disrespectful jabs
it was a two-piece and i was like i
think that sort of hurts i think it was
the third game that pissed me off he was
like warming up on our side right he's
got these trx bands going he's throwing
and i'm like bro i've got nothing but
respect for you but
you being over here is
messing up my juju yeah like my feng
shui my zen my happiness and i'm like
i'm gonna let this [ __ ] rock right i
think i get a sack on them in that game
and so we beat him three times in a row
like that's so tough like that's so
tough especially in football yeah
so i think i missed him like no he likes
my sauce i'm gonna send him some juice
and so i sent him a great bottle of cab
he's too much of a baller for me but i
think one of those physical specimens
he's it yeah like my first time i ever
hit cam newton our rookie year i'd hit
him dead in the chest
and he eats it
turns and like runs for another 15. and
i'm like
oh [ __ ]
quarterbacks are different yeah
quarterbacks aren't different
big dudes i'm like oh it's him and
there's lebron james and then i met
lebron and i was like he's a little
skinnier than i thought he's basketball
big he's two he's 270. he's basketball
big on the sixth
guard right zion is big when i think i'm
honest when i think big i'm like zion's
big like six seven but two
whatever but looks it they don't say
like sex like you could huh and like
different you like that yeah yeah
i feel like if i did this to lebron
lebron would shift a little bit
so what nba player would other than zion
injuries aside right now that you think
would be a good football player is this
panning all the time that in my mind or
is this just like right now let's say
all time and then right now so two i
would say big baby definitely could have
been a 310 he played i think that's not
playing football i think he played a
little bit more like lsu i mean he had
the size of where with all he could have
been
three two shockingly quick great size oh
physical i think lebron would have been
a phenomenal tight end would have been
true
i don't know if he'd ever played a wide
receiver no no he just he was too tall
like he'd have no knees you're 6'9
running down there i'm not like no one
in our safety line is ever going to be
like oh yeah i'm going to talk with them
no you know taking them shins off
absolutely we talked about basically
everybody else except for you and so for
me it's just kind of like when we start
talking about you we got to bring out
the good stuff it's a nichola nickel
they're an awesome place to go visit i
love their tasting room uh their
winemakers are cool too shout out to joe
and phil
you have established yourself not only
as a pro bowler as a leader you're
different but you're different in a good
way and i think you are leading a new
generation of guys who are not hiding
behind the helmet these 90s kids
definitely don't hide behind helmets
you've not missed a game
ever god is good what's different about
you my mother prayed for me every day i
don't know you know like
there's some luck there's some blessings
that have been passed down um and this
idea of attrition i mean
when i think longevity i think about you
know
when i was younger i never really
understood like pops retired when i was
like four i know my mom she was our
first goalie first quarterback first
whatever you know she did it all with us
um and you just don't ever think about
stopping it's just having that motive
that doesn't stop i look at my dab he
still works out five times a week
like you know what i'm saying like he's
oh you're dead stop it he's a he's a
legend like i'm like bro he took it took
two sons to equal one dad you know like
i got the football world but my dad also
went to brown so he's an engineer so
brother does the engineering thing but
it all comes down to it's like the more
you can do like whatever you think
you're doing you can always do more yeah
so i sort of live like that one percent
better every day rule and in that you
know being blessed with with health like
everybody's had
mags whatever it is you know oh i've got
a herniated disc whatever whatever you
know whatever oh i have a herniated yeah
you play 12 games on it whatever that is
i play one game because my stomach hurt
one time this is the the basketball
mentality that we talked about
i've gone to the sideline and re you
know relocated here yeah yeah yeah same
here same here none of these have not
been dislocated dislocate them you pop
them back in and you keep on going it's
like oh ken but you broke a rib so it
was a real how many older ribs do we
have see i don't know about that i never
broke a rib obviously because i'm not
tackling other 300-pound human beings
but like my conditioning mentally is if
i'm not in the field who's on the field
if oh yeah you know i'm saying my
condition is is like if i'm trying to
get my team to be as close as we can to
be the strongest leak there can be no
weak leak and i feel like when i'm on
the field i am our best available option
so when it comes down to games i played
in almost every one of them i didn't
start won my rookie year because i
wasn't in on some uh some sub package
which pissed me off and it and it
inspired me to be like all right well if
i can't be on this nickel package
they're going to see me as a defensive
end i'm going to be
one through four if there's a fifth down
and i want it and i have to i'll fight
coaches on the sidelines like hey cam
you're out this rep you're out this
round like what are you like what do you
mean these are my reps and it's like so
when you look back at us like hey cam
you know you've played 160 games i'm not
even looking forward to that i'm looking
for the next snap you know i'm always
looking ahead i'm looking towards the
next play what gets me closer to the
season so we're gonna play a new game
called nba nfl and the first question is
what's harder to win an nba finals or a
super bowl super bowl why you only get
one shot
one game and the nba finals are seven
games two bowl if you can win any given
sunday cause you could be a better team
17 weeks out of 17 and still lose on
that super bowl sunday
okay so
i don't disagree with you but you said
how hard is it to be the same team
three times no doubt so think about a
team that is equally as good as you that
you've played twice already
that you got to beat four times
if it's a sweep i'd say the finals thing
okay
but if it's just very evenly matched
it's harder to win a super bowl
because it's two if it ends up three
three it's harder to win like it all
comes down now you guys are completely
just in one game yeah it just comes down
to one game okay super bowl it is just
one game you better have your a game
pat mahomes out there balling be had in
office alignment right
that's the only sunday you had to show
up for the super bowl who's more
unguardable
lebron or derrick henry
richard are we talking about
we're talking about 2016 lebron 2016
2017 lebron it's hard to
that's tough derek henry you just got to
catch him going lateral if you're coming
downhill you're not stopping him i
probably say it's hard to guard lebron
okay that's like giannis coming down
full steam like you're gonna you see
they're a foul or a bucket last question
top to bottom who has better athletes
football or basketball top to bottom
man that's that's tough because i was
initially going to say football easily
said or some of our d lyman can easily
match anybody on a basketball roster um
but then i thought about it if i say
your top ten versus my top ten so you
would say we'd easily we've had this
conversation before but we had it with
right all sports where we go who's your
top athlete for football you would say a
wide receiver or a d or a quarterback
right maybe
right somebody say d lyman okay a d-line
who's the most athletic d-lineman in the
nfl right now
pure either chase young or um miles
garrett oh my scare is a friend a freak
of nature six six six two seventy he's
43 armadillo yeah yeah yeah four or five
forty okay freak of name so miles
garrett yep right for you is our
who's your most athletic player
wow
buddy i would have to say
prime russell westbrook okay
okay so those two would be there now
who's your
least athletic oh yeah that's that's
that's why i was initially gonna say
football but i was like if you take all
of us like our offensive lineman are
gonna hold us back quarterbacks will
hold you back too
tom brady is not that fast no doubt
because as we talked about earlier i
like quarterbacks are not going to be
that athletic
in the old mold
right now oh now it's different it's
different i mean quarterbacks are very
different yeah hey jack prescott lamar
russell wilson aaron rodgers even i'm
more worried about where they would
raptors be moving like that oh he's a
phenomenal finesser in the pocket stop
it bro he because he has the arm to do
so he'll throw 50 off the back leg just
chilling like off a fly by about to get
smacked i'm more worried about where
where the quarterback is than i am
office alignment not to take away from
office of lineman but i do
like
i just think as a natural enemy like
they're speed bumps that get in my way
right you are there you they are a cobra
you are a mongoose they are like an
alligator
and i would be like a cheetah like they
could overpower me sure but how can they
catch it if you get pancake blocked do
you just hate yourself no because
everybody gets got but i'm gonna get
them more than i get guys let me think
of who's the slo oh jared dudley
by far don't no look look that's a hot
name
i've got to go out of my way to make fun
of jared dudley because as an athlete
he is the opposite of what i think is
athlete he has athletic hands we used to
make this joke he has
dude this was probably one of my
favorite interviews you're the first nfl
player we've had on the show as much as
we've been probably the last but no
no we want that we need that i loved
introducing these ones to you have a
sips with you good luck this season i
appreciate you having me um especially
knowing another arizona boy in fact a
chandler boy and his valley guys come on
now see town's finest always standing up
um
to be in for the same space
i'm uh i'm just blessed with the
opportunity to pop up
it's awesome and i'm always here for a
good cab
cheers
[Music]